all right then let's dance because that
tonight we're gonna do something a
little bit different I want to do
something slightly offbeat tonight so
we'll look at this position here and
then we'll read the comment from the
person on YouTube that submitted this
opening but we'll get it on the board
really quick let's that let's get to it
all right so d4 and we'll be checking it
out from a blacks point of view tonight
and Knight f6 okay so far everything's
perfectly normal black is taking control
he's not letting you play e4 so white
will almost always play see for the idea
is to play Knight c3 and then try to get
efore in if black allows it and okay we
have a ton of moves here so the most
popular is six and then usually you get
an Enzo Indian but you could get a
Queen's Indian or a catalan depending on
on White's mood you might also expect
the Kings you know Indian or maybe if
you play here maybe you'll get a
grünfeld who knows this move is you know
more popular than what we're going to
see tonight so is this even this is but
tonight we're going to be looking at the
move Knight to c6 so a very unusual move
and this leads us into the Black Knights
tango so not only is it a cool name I
want to read the comment from me love
peas too can you guys cover the Black
Knights tango it's not very popular but
there's nothing wrong with it smiley
face so yeah I think that's pretty
accurate and it's interesting because I
always ask people before my lectures you
know what do you guys think of this
opening and whatever and you know the
resounding response this week was well
that's terrible you can't be playing
this I mean look Knight to c6 right it
just looks awful but I do tend to agree
with me love Peas because I do think you
get some sound positions and I think no
matter what line they play you will get
a perfectly fine and playable position I
don't think it's dubious it's you know
it's not the wandering King that Danny
Machuca loves you know you're not just
playing ridiculous moves on purpose I
think it's fine and here there's
actually three moves that we're going to
be looking at tonight so we'll check out
three different games in it
it's very provocative right you're
bridging pretty much I'm daring you to
try to crush me get the big pond Center
kick my knight around and that's why
it's called the tango they can attack
your Knight kick it all around the board
a couple times and blacks going to hope
you create a lot of weaknesses in the
process and okay White's going to just
try to crush you immediately so the
three main moves here are d5 so we'll
take a look at that first Knight to c3
okay that's a logical enough move and
then okay but it does allow the move e5
by black which is why the most popular
response is Knight to f3 so we'll take a
look at that last but let's accept a
challenge let's see d5
can white just blow black off the board
does this move work because if it does
then this might just be refuted right if
we just get all of our pawns out and
crush black then that would mean you
couldn't play this way so this is you
know a critical line we want to see if
it works
and your knight is attacked so you got
to move it and it's sort of similar to
Alekhine's defense right where they you
know you encourage them to attack your
knight and you move it around only in
the alkyne normally the pawns it's the e
pawn that makes it to here and white
sets up his pawns on dark squares but in
this opening you're going to see white
set up his pawns on light squares which
makes a little bit of a difference for
one thing when black gets a chance to
attack the center which he's going to
need to do when he gets the chance he's
going to play the move like e6000 or
Mele you attack the center with d6 this
enables black to get his Bishop out so
he's usually going to one of these two
squares and the black side just from
personal experience this is something I
used to play a lot is usually easier to
play than white because your plan is
almost always the same and it's usually
white that has to decide what setup he's
going to pick and for some reason
occasionally when I have openings that I
do really well with I just stop playing
them so this one I used to play it all
the time my good success and then I just
stopped playing it for some reason so I
don't know something about my
personality that's something I do a lot
all right already we have a threat so
we're going to go take your pawn so it
has to be really careful here and I
think people unfamiliar with this
position make a lot of mistakes there is
sort of the move you want to play is
efore which is very possible that's
actually the main move but you know some
people will defend with a queen or the
pond or you know though even the only go
to e3 and today we're going to look at a
game or somebody played Queen to c2 and
they you know it's not like a big
developing move you're not getting a big
center but we'll look at this one which
that's a good point so right so the
Queen here are we're defending the pond
we're defending e4 so we're ready to
push our pond and we're defending c3 so
in a lot of lines whenever we get
checked we're gonna you know they're
gonna be able to put at night here and
the knight will be safe because the
Queen will be protecting it so you might
not be able to damage white spawns but
it is worth showing one game just
because it's it's so outstanding I
wanted to show this game where somebody
really really tried to crush black and
you know just really went for it they're
gonna play f4 and just try to crush them
okay so black here played this move of
course not here you know you're not just
winning this pawn because I what is what
does black have sorry what does White's
move here there's actually two moves
that win pretty easily right Queen e2
which is definitely one of the ways and
then yeah it's hard for you to sort all
this out also Queen to d4 is a little
more accurate because then yeah you know
the computer wants you to like set your
knight you just take it with a queen so
we got black has to be a little bit
careful there so he attacks the center
and white goes for it right I'm just
going to crush you I'm gonna push all my
pawns so you got to move your knight and
all right things are looking you know
like okay for white you know if I get a
few more moves I'm going to get my
Knights out I'm going to protect my
Center you can play here immediately
white showed a little bit of restraint
in the following game here let's see if
I can tell you who this was this was
albergue similan from a 1999
correspondence game so okay so he took
and now what's going on here
the knight jumped in so after he takes
are we getting trapped in there what's
what's going on what what does black's
big point well whenever you move your f
pawn you want to be looking for the the
big Queen check and whether you know
that works and can win you the game so
here the move Queen h4 is a very good
move you have to block with your jeep on
if you don't you know anywhere you go
with the king you're going to end up
getting checkmated so you got to play
this move and at the right moment we're
going to play Knight takes g3 and
exploit the fact that there's a pin here
on the H file okay but he played a
slightly more accurate move he threw
this check in and this gives white the
opportunity to make a big mistake which
happened in this game he should just
develop his Knight if he plays Bishop to
d2 which is what happened in this game
he's putting his bishop in a pin this
will be you know important in just a
second here so now he takes all right so
he's threatening to move the knight so
you got to do something and white was
counting on this resource Knight to f3
but he's actually in some serious
trouble here because Black has an
outstanding move so I had to show it
when I saw this okay I have to show you
this game so you might want to pause
your videos at home and we'll see if our
audience here can figure out what it
black do in this position because it's
an amazing move awesome right awesome
yeah so yeah Knight takes f4 so I yeah I
bet white was shocked here like what
impossible and the point is yeah if you
take the Queen as Dennis said checkmate
so that would end the game right there
so Wow yeah that just came out of
nowhere
if this bishop weren't pinned then you'd
be able to just take this and that the
combination wouldn't work so okay and
the game continued white got his Bishop
out of the way it was attacked and after
this trade black played another amazing
move so the good moves just keep coming
for him and this time Queen Age 3 so the
same motif yeah if you take the Queen
you're going to get checkmated so very
clever stuff he decided to move his rook
and after he took the knight here
black was up to ponds and his King is
much safer and he got a very
easy and nice game to play so black was
able to convert this so that does show
the danger you can get into a lot of
trouble you just try to blow them off
the board that can get you into some
trouble here but okay we're going to
look at a another game right now and
this is bonito versus mano latte from
our 2006 so the player with the white
pieces was a 2100 and the player with
black was close to 2500 so a big
disparity in raving and and it showed in
this game so okay Queen c2 we should
attack the center all right white gets
the big center that he wants and now
black will make a decision where are you
going to put your Bishop and are you
going to take here immediately
or not in the game he decided to take
immediately which you don't have to and
he threw in the check so he's decided
where he wants his Bishop to go and you
can defend either way I think this move
makes the most sense that's the most
natural square for the knight so okay
you can also play Bishop to d2 with you
know a little bit of a different game
but alright for time we'll just will
focus here and now there's one big
mistake you can make when you play this
so if you're if you play this is black
you really got to know this one trick or
you can lose a lot of games fast black
is probably considering two moves either
castling or d6 but d6
is a horrible blunder so white here has
a little tactic so let's see see if we
can find it and pause your video do you
see what white would play in this
position
do you have it awesome alright Dennis is
on fire tonight
Queen a5 check and ok you can't save
your Bishop so whatever you do you lose
your bishop Boop
all right so that's a recurring theme
because you get these positions all the
time where you can play the move d6 but
you want to make sure your castle door
that there's no check on h4 on a4 sorry
okay so he castled first excellent and
in the game a little bit of a mistake
was played it's kind of hard for white
here he needs to come up with a plan how
should he develop his pieces and black
will usually do the same things he'll
move his Knights around get his Bishop
out and it's white that has to decide
how are you going to set up your pieces
and okay in the game he chose Bishop to
g5 which is a mistake in a very
instructive one so we'll look at that
but I think it's worth wondering you
know what happens if we play f4 isn't
that a critical line what happens in
here so I'll just show one brief line
that could happen all right so what's
going to defend the center blacks going
to attack it and we'll just get some
position where we've castled here and we
know white is about to have a big
advantage he has the nice Center if you
can get a couple more developing moves
if you could just have the move h3 in it
would stop
you know blacks good move that he can
actually play here but after Knight to
g4 black is just in time to get
something going his lead in development
was just enough that he could get a good
position here and already there's
there's some problems based on the fact
that Bishop to c5 check is really
annoying and it's it's a pretty serious
threat so he has to do something but
lives blunder so we can we can show the
point we'll just move the bishop and
will allow Bishop to c5 check and after
the King moves I mean there's nothing
else to move that I think most people
would play here will work but there's an
even better move so I guess what would
you guys play in a position like this it
looks like we're getting them good here
what's that III with the bishop all
right you're just trying to trade
dark-squared bishop s' is that your say
your point and then if I take ya the
knight will fork me okay so what if I
defend this square okay I just don't
want you to put one of your pieces here
and I don't want you to put a piece here
so these are all common motifs in this
position here so I get one move maybe
I'll be able to stop all your threats so
that's an interesting idea and it works
if your opponent plays along and takes
your bishop and you get to fork them but
I think most people here would probably
play Knight to f2 that looks like a good
move and white is compelled to take with
the rook because you know not taking
your there's going to be some problems
so this does win in exchange and so
that's pretty good but there's an even
stronger move here and that move is
Knight takes H to the point is pretty
much whatever you're doing here I'm
bringing my Queen in and this Bishop is
you know stopping your King from moving
so the real point too if you take you
just get checkmated so you wouldn't be
able to take and this is a little bit
stronger than if you just put the knight
on f2 in this position but it just goes
to show whenever white spends a lot of
time you know attacking all of your
pieces and you know moving all this
pawns forward especially that F pawn a
lot of bad stuff can happen on on some
of these diagonals here so okay so we
castled first in the game Bishop to g5
and this is a nice mistake to make
because it's something that I see a lot
of you know people doing and here it's a
2100 player that did it you don't
usually want to make this pin when
blacks move h6 is a good move so
whenever you play Bishop to g5 you
always need to be calculating h6 and
here white really doesn't want to take
the knight I mean that's why would you
you know just give your Bishop away for
a night if you're going to do that you
probably should have just stayed home
and try to stay on your natural diagonal
hmm so yes so he must go back here he
could go back but also that's you know
this is probably his best move he should
just retreat he went back and now he's
going to compel white to take this night
anyway which is why this move wasn't
very good wait at some point is thinking
about playing f4 so it makes sense to
want to move this Knight just so that f4
doesn't come with tempo and here you get
to attack the bishop so now white pretty
much has to take the night and then
admit that he's worse
so this Bishop soiree didn't really work
for him one point is if we go back here
black has a simple little tactic
hopefully you guys can see it you can
just take this pot so exploiting the pin
so that's why white he has to take this
and we take back and blacks position is
much better we got the two bishops it's
not obvious why white center was pushed
and something that seems to happen
occurred in this game whenever you play
this line people always from move one
they're thinking you know I got to crush
you there's something wrong with this
opening I need to always be thinking
about crushing you and that kind of last
long into the game even when people are
worse or something they're still
thinking well I got to just keep doing
something crazy and crush you to prove
that this opening is unsound so here
white when Queen side which is very
dangerous but maybe he's still hoping
alright I'm still going to get these
guys rolling somehow someday and I'm
going to attack you and my attack is
going to be faster but it turns out that
that's probably not the case in this
situation so okay black he needs to make
a move
let's get our pieces out and Black's
attacking plan is he's going to get this
Bishop out of the way and he can open
the C file at his choosing and he could
bring one of his rooks to the C file and
that's coming pretty quickly wait on the
other hand if he chooses some sort of
slow attacking plan like all these moves
it's going to take him three four or
five moves to even start his attack and
black will be a little bit quicker over
here so he decided again not a
developing move
but he doesn't want after Knight to f3
for black to be able to play Bishop to
g4 so that's why he played here and okay
so we see it striking at the center and
he really doesn't mind he's hoping that
you take this because opening the B file
is going to be excellent for black and
the fact that you have you know weakened
pawns there in the center yeah you got
some hanging pawns that's not as
important as the dynamic play that
blacks going to get so lots of these
positions in the tangle the end up being
really dynamic where it's more important
to have active and powerful pieces than
it is to have a healthy pawn structure
because in this situation everybody's
playing for checkmate here so okay he
got his Knight out he got the Bishop out
of the way now a rook is coming to c8
and alright it's not easy to play white
in this position let's see what he did
so he moves the King out of the way and
either rook can go to c8 but uh alright
he's looking pretty good in this
position okay so alright not too not the
best maybe he did want to make sure his
rook was always protecting this deep on
so we'll see what happened now
he took the knight and it's you know
interesting this was always something
that white had to calculate what happens
if he takes my knight well I have to
take with my queen or wif upon and he
took with a pawn if you take with the
Queen which is also you know a thing it
might even be a little bit better once
you see the game you might think that
this the position you'll see here is a
little bit better so black can either
just grab this pawn and he's a pawn up
black is much better in this position so
but he can also not do that he can just
take here not win any material in this
line after something like this he's not
up any material but his position is
great this Knight is looking at all
these excellent dark squares the rook is
going to swing over here and if Knight
to b3 one of the points is Bishop to a4
and whatever you do next we grab this
guy and we just continue putting our
pieces on good places and it'll be a
tough endgame for for black to
ultimately win but he's a lot better so
he should have
really good chances of winning so you
can compare that to the game because
what happens in the game is he takes
with his pawn
okay so we take in the center and this
guy is particularly weak so white/black
needs to come up with a way to attack
that pond and there's there's a couple
different ways to do it
rook to c5 is fine and you have to
Knight moves that can do it and he chose
the more active one so Knight to f4 and
you have some problems how do you defend
your pawn one problem for instance is
you can't move your knight away because
either rook takes c3 or Bishop to f5 I
mean miserably f5 looks pretty crushing
here would be pretty bad for you so
notice this Knight is also defending the
f5 square which might be important in a
lot of these lines here so he decided
Queen to b3 it's also worth noting that
if c4 one way black and just keep
attacking is b5 and okay this is going
to be quite good for him
you can't take this either way we're
going to open this up and we're going to
start attacking so he decided Queen b3
that's the way to do it and all right he
attacks the pawn again so he had to
defend with the C pawn and now how to to
keep attacking here well the movie
played in the game was fine I think it's
a move a lot of people would play on
auto-pilot here he brought his rook over
all right doubling your rooks which is
obviously very good for him but he
didn't miss a chance to play an even
stronger move which is b5 and yeah it's
hard to do anything about that
for example if you take with the night
what would black play here
rook b8 this also probably is a strong
move but yeah yeah you're missing a
meeting it attack here
Bishop to f5 check yep so then when the
knight is missing this is a pretty bad
414 white over here so right so this
looks pretty strong if you run away
you're going to get checkmated the
strongest move here is to take the
knight and with the knight gone
whatever you whichever way you take we
got it you know your Kings wide open
we got a queen in a row because I can
check you so either of them will win the
fastest is with the Queen in this
particular case and okay so let's just
let's just get checkmated here right so
you imagine that there must be some sort
of mating attack when you're that wide
open and there is so b5 a very strong
move but this move is fine as well black
is still enjoying everything about this
position so let's see the knight was
attacked and he found a way to win upon
here pretty good he traded these guys
and then he took this and white really
shouldn't take that night but he really
did and now he's losing so again you may
want to pause your videos this one isn't
terribly tough but what was the move
here that black played
yeah yeah rook to c1 and okay this move
was I played in a white resigned here
he's going to lose a piece so he's going
to have to play King to a3 and if only
Dani Machuca were here we could talk
about blacks next move because I'm sure
I haven't talked to Dani about this
position yet but I guarantee you he
would just trade the Queens because
that's what he likes to do in these
positions he always will trade down to
an the endgame and all right this is
just sort of a different chess
philosophy obviously you can either
trade Queens or you can take here
immediately so I wish it was here we
could fight about it because this is you
know something that we we always talk
about and I've talked about it before in
these videos I would keep the Queens on
the board here because your king is here
and my king is really safe so if you
want to train Queens with me that's fine
but I'm keeping the Queens on the board
here this would be my move and ought to
ask Danny is that what he would play
because I I'm pretty sure it would be
that's that's his style so okay well
we'll go back a little bit and check out
a different line here all right so this
next game that we're going to look a
look at this is a Spiller Orlov from
1991 so and in this game we're going to
look at a different move Knight to c3
and there's you know there's a more than
one thing that black can do here it is a
rather flexible opening because you
haven't committed to anything in the
center we're going to look at E 5 which
is by far the the main line here but you
can consider ecigs hoping for you know
some sort of nimzo-indian you might be
able to try you know d6 and then you've
tried to play a Kings Indian but we're
going to look at E 5 today which is you
know what your your typical tango move
would be in this position and white
doesn't have to push though he almost
always does he could for example play
here and transpose to the English for
Knights so that is something that you
probably want to look at and I think
that the English for Knights is actually
kind of interesting even though
there's somebody at the club right now
that I know thinks it's a pretty boring
opening but I think it's pretty rich in
possibilities so I like it
alright d5 instead of the night must
retreat so normally we're going to go
this way it is probably possible to go
to be 8:00 and then you know try to play
moves like this and get your night to c5
that's a very common way to play but
this is by far the more popular way what
gets the center we move our night and
here's where the position really begins
for this line so most of these moves are
played in almost every game and we get
here and again it's white that has to
decide how he's going to set up all of
his pieces and black it's it's easy
again you know we just we choose which
scare we want for the bishop we Castle
we play d6 and then we start attacking
the center black is usually you know
it's pretty easy to play this so okay
what Y can choose you can do something
modest you know he can just get his
Knight out
he can play lines where he plays f3 or
h3 but the most common way is Bishop to
e3 and that was played in this game and
that does cut out one of blacks options
now you're not going to play Bishop to
c5 so that's been ruled out so it's
obvious where the bishops going it's
going to be four and okay notice too
that even if you play Queen to c2 as if
this was an Enzo Indian it doesn't
prevent black from doubling the pawns
because you can take here and you can't
take with the Queen because you're a
pawn is hanging so okay in the game he
decided he play f3 okay that makes makes
sense and black takes immediately again
we can blunder so yeah hopefully yeah
you see it this time - what white would
play here again this check will win the
bishop so yeah hopefully that was on
your radar and this is your last chance
if you want to double his pawns you
don't have to but it's a seems like a
perfectly fine way to play now d6 is
fine there's no risk because our Bishop
you know Oh peace accept isn't hanging
over here because he's gone and all
right for some reason now this position
almost everybody plays the same plan as
White
which is you know to get rid of their
double bond but this is something that
blacks should actually welcome because
when they do that they open the see file
so I think white should probably look
for some different plan in this position
but this is what everybody seems to do
so fine
we castle and g3 which we see a lot in
in positions all right you're just
trying to keep my night out all right
fair enough but now Black has a good
plan you can threaten to win this pawn
I'm forcing you to open the C file and
now we'll get some really good play on
the C file the queen is looking at a
good square here eventually one of these
rooks might come over we're going to get
some pressure down the C file and this
Knight has an awesome home too so blacks
position here is already much better so
right so let's attack the pawn white
will defend it and let's get that night
in there so here white was thinking all
right he wants to take my bishop and he
didn't want to lose his bishop all right
that's fair enough so he put his bishop
back and all right how to make progress
here as black he's doing pretty well on
the Queen side and the good thing is he
can play on both sides of the board here
he knows white is about to castle he can
consider you know interrupting his plans
but black had a pretty good idea in this
game f5 so when white castles his plan
is to open the F file and get control so
if he can do this and he can take
control over the F file then all of his
pieces are going to be better than
whites so here he did take and in this
position he forced white to make a
decision with his rook so you don't have
to trade rooks here you could play rook
f2 or something like that but he did
trade and now it's black that owns the F
file so if you just take a look at the
quality of some of these pieces here
you'll notice they're a lot better than
all of White's pieces and okay we have a
threat we're going to play rook to f1
which in this position you'd have to
take with a queen
so white decided alright I'm going to
get out of that and play Queen to d2 but
this falls for a little tactic here so
black played another really nice move in
this position all of his pieces are
better so the tactic should favor him
and so here he played a nice move yes
anyone see it yeah yeah good job
yeah Queen takes a to attacking the rook
and yeah so the obvious point is if we
we take this Queen it's checkmate and
then so it's funny so white saw in this
position that he can't take the Queen
but then he decided to put his rook on
b1 which is funny because what did black
play he played one more move in this
game yeah right so he saw that you
couldn't do that and then he allowed
Queen takes rook and now the game's over
you're getting mated in one or two moves
here but what's really funny about this
position here is this is this exact
position occurred in a different game
ten years later so there's a game with a
Joel Benjamin they had this exact same
position even though they reached it by
a much different move order and a
different number of moves but all right
so it occurred in that game white may
black try a little bit harder he you
know moved the rook to e1 and the game
didn't last much longer so we'll breeze
through this but okay protects his
knight he's attacking e4 all right he
gets these pawns going route gets all
better and yeah pretty soon he's like
alright enough and this is pretty bad
you know he's he's going to win some
stuff here and but it's just funny
because the same exact position occurred
again and in a different order so all
right one more game here alright so this
final game here this is going to be my
Rob vs. as our off from our 2005 you
probably make fun of me for every name
I've said tonight because I'm not
pronouncing any of them right but
look at the most critical line so this
is a big majority of tango games are
there in this line and people play
really wacky stuff here but okay these
moves are both really terrible so I
don't advise them but the big moves here
are either X or D six you can play D six
with the idea of transposing to a Kings
Indian if you if that's what you want to
play for example you know we're going to
get like a mainline Kings Indian here so
something like that is very possible and
the other possible way to play after
Knight to f3 is e six which is you know
the more popular move and after Knight
to c3 we've actually transposed to an
Enzo Indian and this is the zurich
variation which hasn't always been the
most popular move but I suspect at club
level this opening is going to get a lot
more popular because there was a book
written by Christoph Sulekha also known
as chess explained and you're on
youtubes you know chess explained in his
book is excellent I have it so it's I do
recommend it it's a good one and so he
covers lines where black puts his knight
on c6 so what could the point be well
let's let white defend his knight here
and the point is he's going to use a
dark-squared strategy he knows at some
point he's going to be forced to cough
up his bishop here so he's going to lose
the bishops so that's a big plus for
white so in order to compensate for that
he's going to put all of his pawns on
dark squares so the knight on c6 will
help you when you play the move e5 and
at some point whenever they you know
play d5 your knight we'll go back and
we'll see a little bit more once we get
there why that's a okay move all right
so this move which is considered better
than a3 a3 is the other big move here
but in this position white intends to
keep the Queen on c2 where she's eyeing
the e4 square which is very important in
this line and all right the most
accurate move here is the castle other
moves haven't tried but they are a
little bit slow you do need to be
careful F white gets these moves in
really quick you can get into some
trouble here
so castling
is best and now let's get the bishop and
what should be happy here he is a little
bit better in this position it's you
know it's pretty pleasant to play white
here you got the two bishops you got a
little bit more space but it's you know
let's check it out let's see what what's
going to happen here so we want to play
e5 so let's get our Queen here and now
white makes a big decision because what
are you going to do with this Bishop so
there's three moves that you might
consider in this position III is
actually the most popular so we'll check
that out efore is also a very critical
line to which black will play d5 you
might even consider g3 and putting the
bishop on g2 this also is very possible
but I think the restraint III is White's
best try for an advantage here he's
keeping the e4 square free of a pond so
he's going to occupy it with pieces
later on and at some point I will play
you know probably Bishop to d3 getting
even more control over that Square all
right
and now with this move we can blunder
with white that that's possible so black
has stopped too this move from happening
if he plays Bishop to e2 it might run in
to Bishop to g4 and white probably
doesn't want to trade pieces he's got
the big space advantage here so the move
that I think white should play here if
we can see after d5 sorry
you know the knight goes back is to play
the move Knight to d2 the purpose of
this move is not to allow you to ever
play Bishop to g4 in a situation where
you might be able to take you know one
of our pieces and we're getting ready
now to play Bishop to d3 without having
to worry about
efore forking our pieces so a very good
move and the most popular move in this
position and this hasn't been played a
whole lot of times so there's probably a
lot of room here to come up with some
new stuff is c6 and if white takes you
take back with the knight also very
popular I guess is a5 this makes some
sense you know a lot of lines you want
to stop white from playing b4 and just
getting a lot of space on the Queen side
but this game amused me because of this
next maneuver so for that reason alone I
decided
to talk about this game and it wasn't
covered extensively in celexa all right
I didn't want to pick something somebody
has already talked about Knight to e8 so
yeah an unusual move which is why it's
only been played once like what 98
what's the point of this move well
alright white said you show me what is
the idea and here
Queen to g5 so very interesting he's
attacking the g2 pond and in the game we
decided to play g3 and then he cancelled
queenside he thought it was was too
risky to Castle I mean what happens if
you do Castle this is something we
should check out really briefly here
well he must have seen Bishop to h3 and
you got to do something here you can't
play g3 or I take your rook so you got
to defend g2 and maybe it was this move
f5 that kind of threw him off he's like
what I mean black might be getting
pretty active here he's starting to play
e4 I'm gonna have to either play e4
myself or I might have to play King h1
and just get out of the pen and so who
knows what lines he calculated but he
decided I'm not going in for that g3 and
now a funny thing happened Queen to e7
so it's the Queen's tango yeah an
interesting maneuver Queen to e7 to g5
to e7 but he provoked g3 and he
convinced white to Castle queenside so I
guess that's a success for black and so
that's where white went and so we got
sort of a similar scenario where white
should start thinking about how he's
going to you know attack on the Kings
side
Black's going to be looking at some of
the same moves that we've seen before we
should be thinking about attacking
opening up some lines over here but
first let's go ahead and throw the move
a5 in here just so we might be able to
lock down on your pawns and that'll make
it easier for us to open up your
position later on if we can play a four
then these ponds will be kind of stuck
and it'll be easy for me to open up
lines so white said b3 so if you ever
play a4
or I can play b4 and keep things closed
over there and our it's time to get our
pieces out tonight is going to c5 that
was the intentional along with Knight to
b8 and then yeah white played kind of
interesting I think it makes more sense
for him to consider just going for it
here because that's something that he
does adopt later on but he doesn't you
know get it in quite in time and black
is a little bit faster in this game
perhaps he's hoping maybe sometimes
there's going to be tricks here but
we'll see what happens here
Knight to c5 and so now he's going for
it he's going to try to open up some
stuff over there and an interesting
thing happens in this game too every
time you think you know black is about
to do something over here on the Queen
side he surprises you and he does
something over on the Kings side so okay
a couple normal moves are played but now
the knight is thinking about going to g4
where it would be forking two pawns so
what is y gonna do he defends one of his
pawns and the knight goes to g4 anyway
alright
Yuri pawn is attacked so he gets his
Bishop out of the way defending his pawn
and it's interesting this move Knight g4
you know you can is it a good move or
not his point now is he wanted to play
the move f6 which he thinks will be a
good defensive move if white ever takes
here we'll take back and the fact that
the pawn structure will be symmetrical
will make it hard for you to crash
through but now white does get to get
his attack going so right so the pawns
are rolling forward and he's getting
ready to play g5 so you should probably
stop them
so Knight to f7 was played but what's
going on is white actually encouraging
is black encouraging like to get a big
attack here is this all been miss played
by black it's it's kind of interesting
how was black going to get his attack
going because White's coming now and
he's coming pretty fast so okay so he
wants to play you know move like g5
but all right so he's got to lock this
down and now he's going to play h4 and
g5 so also another point of getting this
this night out of the way is you can
play rook to b8 okay so he's getting
ready here come these moves Black's
going to try to get to him who's going
to be there first so white thinks
alright I'm going to stop you from
playing here but he is playing on the
side where his opponent is attacking him
so this actually might give black some
opportunities to open things up you know
he can play c6 and b5 and this might
actually be a liability for him and so
black decides ah you know he's going to
start to attack the center white has you
know the same ideas but here he actually
makes a big mistake he was always
thinking he would protect his pawn here
with a move like 'if or and then that
gives him the opportunity to start
rolling these guys but this is actually
a big mistake white has an awesome move
here that he didn't find because blacks
position is much better he's a he's
about to really open up the King and his
attack is coming faster but if white
found the right move here then his game
might have been okay and that move is
Knight to d4 okay now we see the rook on
the same file at the Queen that's
finally meaning something because if we
allow you to jump in here then that's a
pretty good night and that would be
really annoying so black almost has to
take this in after okay we're going to
lose one of our piece so desperado we
move our Queen back away this is not so
easy for black to open up the position
here we can play a move like Bishop to
g22 at least for a while stop you from
playing this move based on the fact that
we can now take here so this would have
been interesting and you know white
would probably be okay in a position
like this but it's a it's a difficult
move to find and the idea of playing
efore and getting these guys going seems
like a very sensible way to play here
so black is thinking about b5 and he has
to be really careful if he plays b5
right away he's thinking white is going
to be able to take here in between so
black can consider sacking a piece if he
wants in the game he put his Bishop back
so now he could play b5 and this move
won't come with tempo you know it's it
is kind of unclear if this piece sac
shouldn't work or not because okay you
attacked the bishop obviously we can't
just take here or what gets too close
everything up and now you're your attack
is gone but you could consider taking
here this is a you know an exciting
sharp way to play but it's it's not
clear that this position actually will
be better for black because the best
move here is to take this move is
important because after move like this
he wants to make sure in some lines he
can put a bishop here because the King
probably needs to blockade the pawns
here black has some tricks you know
maybe I can get my Queen on your King
here but it's it's not so easy because
anytime you play d5 I have Bishop to b4
and do you really have enough for your
piece obviously those are pretty nice
pawns but now maybe it'll be White's
turn he's going to get going on the
Kings side and he is up a piece so it's
not really clear that that would be the
best and there's no reason for black to
take the risk in this position so bishop
de 8 makes a lot of sense and what are
you going to do I'm playing b5 next all
right white plays a little bit of
Defense he knows after b5 he's going to
take this way and okay the rook will be
doing some defensive jobs here so b5
comes he does take with the a pawn when
we take back all right so what's
happening it looks looks pretty
dangerous for white so some more stuff
was traded so will that nullify the
attack well probably not
all right and now just again in this
game whenever you think something is
coming over here you know there was
gonna be some sort of attacking move
we're gonna sack something black
surprises white and he plays on the
other side of the board so in this
position not only is he just threatening
the H pawn but if the pawn just moves
say white plays h4 he is thinking about
putting the knight here anyway with the
idea of coming back to f4 and he'll have
two knights looking in at d3 so that is
a major problem and I so I like this the
piece that was doing the least now is
going over on the other side of the
board and causing a lot of trouble and
white decides all right I got a defend
to my pawn but uh all right he's he's in
for a big surprise here now black plays
a very strong move that that is just the
winning move here so you probably he had
to play h4 and allow the knight you know
to maneuver his way to f4 but this move
was played and black played sort of a
simple move it's not a tactic here but
I'll let you guys pause your video and
I'll let the audience here see if they
can find what black played in this
position it's a simple move not it's not
a big tactic or sacrifice or anything
anyone got it all right
the move was Queen to a seven so
eyeballing the rook we're getting ready
to move the night away probably with
cheque and then your book will be
hanging and the problem for white is
it's not easy to move his rook because
if you go back then you're unde
offending your H pawn if you go
laterally then what happens in the game
happens and if you defend it obviously
your book was on a1 for some defensive
reasons so this attack is going to be a
little bit stronger with the rook gun
well he decided okay I want to stay
where I'm protecting the pond and he
must have missed blacks move here so now
this is a tactic it is black to play and
I find the strongest move here
somebody looks like he's thinking about
it looks like he knows who can figure it
out
it is tricky this is actually quite a
nice move the black played here so hope
oh you got it right excellent that was
played and the game came to an end
so yeah awesome the point of this move
is if you capture we can recapture this
and if the Queen takes now hopefully we
can see what Blackwood was thinking am i
playing in this position it's a queen to
f2 and the fork should decide the day
and this position is not fun to to play
if you're white and white said I'm done
that's enough and the game ended right
here so it is very interesting I hope
that gives you just a brief outline of
what happens when you play the tango it
can be a very dynamic exciting opening
and obviously we're a bit unfair to
white it's not like we we gave white a
very you know fair shake and this this
lecture but now that you have the false
impression that the tango just wins by
force we're going to go have the last
round of our tournament tonight and
somebody possibly somebody sitting in
the front row is going to win a book
tonight
you